现代游戏引擎的理论与实践
那么今天的话呢是这个即将开启
我们一个很大的一个section
就是绘制系统
那么现代游戏引擎的绘制系统
将会是一个非常大的一个就是模块
那我们会用四节课的时间给大家讲一下
游戏引擎的绘制是怎么做的
那么实际上的话呢就是从游戏刚刚开始的时候
我们就和绘制走在一起
其实最早的游戏大家知道就是在50年前
那个时候的显示器就像一个示波器
其实在那个示波器时代的话
我们已经很努力的要表现这些画面啊
小飞机飞来飞去对吧
那么就最早的红白机时代的时候
如果大家去读过那个时候的回忆的文章的时候
它实际上是一行一行扫描
每一行只能放几种颜色
现在这种情况下
我们还是很艰难的写了一个绘制系统
然后能够把一些很精彩的游戏奉献给大家
也是我们童年的回忆了
那么实际上在今天的话呢
现代游戏的绘制系统是已经是越来越丰富
越来越复杂
所以就像我们在第一节课跟大家讲过
就是很多人就是提到游戏引擎会下意识的说诶
游戏引擎是不是就是绘制引擎
那显然我们上过我们前三节课的同学
就知道说游戏引擎其实是不止绘制
但是呢绘制呢又是游戏引擎
非常非常重要的一派
而且呢它其实从技术难度
到他的专业的壁垒来讲的话
也是最高的一趴
那么就是这里面我就抛一个问题来了
我们的同学吗
就是有没有游戏是不需要绘制系统的
同学们想一想
那这里面的话跟大家
就是那个啊开个小小的玩笑
其实是有的
比如说有一种文字游戏叫做MAD
就是说你通过打字说你进入了一个房间
然后呢房间里有一张桌子
你要不要走上桌子呢
你跟谁说了一句话呢
其实这种文字游戏它虽然也是电子游戏啊
它其实是不需要绘制系统的
那么但是呢现在大家玩的绝大部分游戏
都是需要绘制的
那这里面的话呢我们要cute cue一下
就是那个101课程了对吧
我们的严厉起闫老师
那么练习的话呢
他在101课程里面给同学们系统的去讲了
就是游戏计算机图形学的一些理论
那这里面的话呢我们学了各种各样的算法
各种各样的基础理论
这些东西的话呢
毫无疑问
他是这个就是游戏的渲染系统的一个基础
那这里面的话呢我们可以看到就是说啊
我们学了那么多知识
那在游戏的渲染系中中中
它的区别是什么呢
其实我们会发现啊
就是在计算机图形学中我们学的东西呢
他第一个解决的问题是比较明确的
比如说你去一般绘制一个或者几个物体
绘制某个特定的效果
比如说我们要绘制这个透明物体translucency
对吧
我们要去那个去做你们的他们的那种
就是那个就是那个比如折射和反射的效果
比如说我们要做水面
我们要做这个3S的这个透半透明材质
那这都是一个非常明确的一个需求
另外一个的话呢
就是说其实在那个图形学理论中啊
我们一般不会特别关注它的硬件是怎么实现的
我们一般会关注他的算法或者数学上的正确性
比如说在我那个大学学图形学的时候
我们学过一个算法叫辐射度算法
他就是一个完全按照光学理论去给出的模型
然后计算机也跑个几天
算出一张非常漂亮的图
他也很好看
所以在我们的那个同学学的时候
我们那时候做到30帧以上
甚至20帧以上
我们就说yeah
我们是个ROA的一个算法
如果呢我只能算到十帧左右
我们叫什么呢
我们叫做interactive
就是说可以交互性的事实了
那实在不行
我不能实时
但是我画面做的特别好
比如像电影级的cg的渲染的话
那我可以是几个小时甚至几天只渲染一帧
那么有的时候数据会大佬
连那个就是内存都装不下去
甚至很多台机器离散的去存储
我们叫什么呢
叫out of CORE rendering
所以这个呢其实是就是理论的图形学
计算机科学学和游戏呢是有一个很大的区别
就在这一点
那么在游戏中的绘制系统
我们面临的挑战是什么呢
第一个挑战呢就是说在游戏的绘制系统里面
我们同时要处理的物体对象
以及物体的各种类型
包括我需要实现的各种效果是极其复杂的
举个例子
就是说在我的场景中
有成千上万的这个物体的对象对吧
而且它每个形形式都不一样
有的是比如像水体
有的是这个这个foliage就是植被
有的是角色
有的是天空中的云
那么我需要用到的这种绘制算法
比如说毛发的算法对吧
皮肤的算法
水体的算法和这个植被的算法
还有地面上材质的算法就完全不一样
然后我整体上还要加大量的后处理
大量的这个就是说光照运算
所以这everything into one container
就是所有东西都放在一个容器里面
那大家想想看
这个游戏的绘制系统是不是会非常的复杂
这是我们的第一个挑战
就是它非常复杂
它是一个all in one的一个组合
那么第二个事情呢
就是说其实在游戏的绘制系统的话呢
我们并不是跑在一个理想的
或者是一个一个idea的一个设备上
就SERRALLY
我们证明它正确了
就能做
恰恰相反
我们需要跑在现代的硬件基础上
比如说这是一个很经典的计算机的
这个PC机的架构对吧
它南桥北桥
如果同学们自己组装过电脑
就知道说诶
我要把这个显卡和这个CPU插在哪个地方
对不对
那么硬盘插在哪个地方
南桥北桥
那我们做的所有的算法
它必须要在这些现代的
比如说我们的PC或者是主机
或者是我们的这个小小的switch上面
要跑得非常的快
那我们就需要对它的硬件了解的非常的深
我才能做的特别好
所以今天的这节课呢会相对来讲有点硬核
我会跟大家讲一些硬件的东西对吧
大家要做好后面高能的准备
我高能之前的话
我一定会给大家做个预警
所以说我们的计算机图形学
渲染系统的第二个挑战呢
就是说你必须要深度的去适配当代的硬件
那么第三个呢
也就是说其实在我们在统计学理论的时候呢
我们其实一般来讲一个算法
我们觉得这个效果做出来了
基本上能达到一个相对好一帧率
我们觉得不错了
但是在游戏中啊
其实你的场景是千变万化的
对不对
但是你的帧率必须是稳定的
举个例子
比如说我不能够一开门走出去
看到一片巨大的山谷
然后呢很开阔的世界突然帧率掉了一半
那大家觉得这个游戏就不好玩了
对不对
我看了那个就是很多在网上
大家看到一些新的游戏的点评的时候
如果发现那个游戏打着打着帧率就掉下去了
你们就会说这是很差的游戏
但是大家想象一下
我们在游戏世界里面
构建的场景是不是非常的多样
一会儿你在一个密闭的小房间里面
就几个怪物围着你打
你突然一下子跑到这个楼顶上
你看到一个整个城市的场景
但是无论你是看到大还是小
无论是细腻的还是粗糙的
它都要保证是在1/30秒
就是30ms跑完
而且现代的游戏呢要求越来越高
比如说我们讲电竞
大家现在打一个FPS游戏的话
我们是不是都要求要60帧呢
对不对
包括现在电竞屏的要求到120帧左右
那么我们的画幅呢又越来越大
最开始的时候我们叫做1080P高清
那现在的话呢
我就我相信我们很多同学的家里的那个游戏
电脑已经全部变成了4K了对吧
即将我们到来的是8K的时代
想象一下
就是说如果大家在做绘制系统
说这个game engine的话
这个压力会多大
也就是给我们的时间越来越小
但是大家对我们画面的要求也越来越高
所以呢在大家去理解
就是说游戏引擎的绘制系统设计的时候
要要理解一件事情
就是说他的这种就是绘制的算法
它必须装在一个非常固定的这个预算里面
就是你绝对不能超过大
你超过大的话
一帧率就掉下去了
那玩家的游戏体验就没有了
所以这也是我们就是做和这个游戏引擎
其他的这个比如说设计师啊
美术啊
天天打架的地方
就是你把这东西弄得太复杂了
那你就会影响我的游戏性了
那么最后一个呢也是同学们可能会忽略的
但是其实呢也很简单的一个道理
就是说我们这个游戏跑在我们的一台电脑上
显卡线我们可能可以百分之百的把它吃掉
但是CPU也就是我们最重要的计算单元
我们可以把它百分之百的吃掉吗
如果把它百分之百的吃掉
那我们前面讲了那么多的游戏逻辑啊
游戏玩法是不是跑不起来了
对不对
包括网络啊
所以实际上的话呢
在我们的就是真正的游戏引擎里面的
绘制系统的话
它不能像我们在图形学课上
我能百分之百的把车计算资源全部吃掉
我们硬盘只能吃掉大概10%到20左右吧
剩下的大部分的话
我们还是要让给我们其他的这种gap类的系统
所以这个呢也是一条阴线
所以说当我们去做一个真实的游戏开发的时候
我们有一个很重要的工作叫做profile
然后呢那那个那个profiling的
现在一般游戏引擎都是全自动的
就是每天我们会自动的去跑
然后会告诉你说
哎你这个系统好像超过了我的预算
你得赶快改回去
否则的话我这个游戏就不许你发布
所以这也是对游戏引擎的绘制
系统的这个巨大的限制
这四点挑战的话呢
也就导致了现代游戏引擎的渲染系统的设计
会和传统的就是计算机图形学的理论
讲的是有比较大的一个差别好
那所以呢我们这一个章节
也就是我们连续的四节课
就是争取用大概四节课的时间
把游戏引擎中的绘制系统给大家讲清楚
在我开始讲这节课之前呢
讲讲这些东西之前
我想给大家建立一个概念
就是我们接下来讲的所有的东西
它不是一个理论模型
它是一个工程实践过的
就是这个非常practical的
而且呢是经过这个行业将近30年的
这个迭代优化
heavily optimized这样的一个software system
也就是说它是个软件工程系统
它是一个实践科学
其实大家以后在学一些理论
和学实践科学的时候
你会发现他们之间有很大的区别
如果学理论科学的同学啊
其实比较舒服
为什么呢
一般理论知识它更新换代的速度不会特别的快
基本上那些基础理论你基本上十几年调一调
问题就不大
你就是差不多它的
就像数学
有些东西你是不会变的
对不对
但是如果你是一个工程实践科学
就是它代表比如说最前沿的制造
制造制造技术
最前沿的计算机的体系结构技术
最前沿的这个游戏引擎的技术
和游戏引擎的渲染技术
那么它更新换代速度是非常的快
因为它是在工程实践中演化出来的
而且呢它是会随着我们的硬件
整个游戏产业的环境的变化
在快速的不断的优化和迭代中
所以在这节课中的话呢
我们不会跟大家纠结一下
它的理论模型是什么样的
我们更多的会跟大家讲什么东西呢
就是说这些工程上为什么是这么做
这么做
为什么是这么多最优秀的聪明的大佬
发现是最优的东西
所以它是一个practical的software system
这个概念的话
我希望同学们建立起来
实际上也是到我们最难的这一趴了
就是今天是那个清明节对吧
我们的课程组的小伙伴们非常的干
其实非常的辛苦
那我们真的是花了很多很多时间在想一个问题
就是说如何把这个游戏引擎的渲染系统
塞到四节课里面
因为大家知道就是游戏引擎啊
这个东西
它本身它的绘制系统本身就可以
成为一个20节以上的基础课程
而且20节还是非常浓缩的
如果我们做一个叫real time rendering in game engine
这应该是这么厚的一本书
没什么太大问题的
然后的话呢
我们20节课给大家建立一个基础概念
也是没有什么太大问题的
但是呢我们的挑战就是说
把这所有的东西用四节课讲清楚
所以呢花了很长时间
我们想了一下
就是说那个我们把这个课程分成四趴
第一part呢
就是今天我们会给大家讲一下
基础的GPU的硬件是怎么回事
包括基于这个硬件的架构
我们对渲染的数据
包括体系是怎么管理的
包括可见性裁剪这些基础的东西
你至少知道说我给了你一堆东西
它怎么画出来对吧
那么第二节课呢
我们会讲一些就是真正在实战的
比如说在现在游戏中
你的光照模型到底是什么
比如说最著名的IB2模型是怎么回事对吧
那么就是那个然后呢给大家介绍
就是现在行业最标准的就是材质系统
比如说PB2的材质
那么两种最经典的材质
它模型它的优异度差别
然后最后呢会跟大家讲一下
就是说我们的SHADER模型
其实你把第二节课听完之后
你基本上能画出一个看上去非常非常就是CBB
就是跟现代游戏看起来很像的这样一些东西
那你就不用再去纠结说我怎么去用这个模型
那个模型基本上你看第二节课的模型的话
做出来的东西看上去就很像我们叫做什么
来叫行货的东西了
那么第三节课呢我们会跟大家同学们讲一些
就是其实游戏中很多很重要的这个子系统
比如说地形系统对吧
还有天空的这个系统
包括后处理系统
其实你们看到很多的3A大作
它的后处理其实是非常非常重要的
这些算法呢其实很深
也比较有比较有挑战性
那当我们在三节课的时间
学会了这所有的基础的数据组织
基础的绘制算法
材质模型之后
那我们要讲什么东西呢
就跟大家讲就拍拍
那大家可能听说过很多很著名的pine
比如说different shading对吧
延迟渲染
那different shading为什么要这么设计
它的点在哪里
包括就是说我们真的去做完了绘制之后
是不是这个不用管
说显卡怎么提交到我们的屏幕上
那这里面他的这种绘制的
这些内容是怎么管理的
包括在屏幕上怎么去
那包括在这里面的话呢
我们也可以跟同学们讲一下
就是现在比较前沿的这个叫TBRENDERING
所以说我们把所有的东西全部压缩到了
这个四节课里面
所以呢应该来讲就是知识密度有点高
有的时候可能有点挑战
如果同学们听不懂
不要慌
没关系
因为我们后面会上传录像到B站上
所以同学们的话呢可以回头再去看
而且呢也不需要全部都懂
因为你只要知道一些核心的东西就可以了
那么今天的这节课呢就是我们可能需要拖点堂
就是我们前面所有的课程
都希望控制在一个小时之内的
今天这个课我目测一下
好像一个小时有点有点难
没关系
就是希望既然是放假了对吧
我们就在一起
好好的在知识的海洋里面遨游一下好
那我们就开始今天的第一节课
就是渲染的基础
那其实呢哦对在这节课里面的话呢
我们虽然已经尽了我们最大的努力
但是我们得向同学们坦诚啊
有些东西我们还是没有办法装进去
实在容量不够了
那比如说大家特别喜欢的这个卡通画渲染
大家都喜欢的二次元游戏
对不对
那其实呢同学们不用慌
因为这个就是说你学完这节课的基础知识呢
你再去上面再学二次元的
就是mp2的非真实感渲染的知识呢
也不会特别难
他其实他用的很多理念跟那比如说post processing啊
后处理啊
这种理念是相通的
那么包括呢像很多的2D游戏
其实我们叫的2D游戏引擎
它有一些很深的一些一些方法论的东西
但是呢现在的其实很多2D引擎
现在也是采取3D引擎的方法
就是把这个东西在3D空间展开来
所以的话呢你这些知识也是可以相通的
当然了还包括一些大家特别喜欢的
比如说非常炫酷的这个皮肤的3S材质对吧
就是半透明效果
比如说我们特别炫酷的毛发效果
这些呢都特别适合作为一些就是独特的专题
跟大家去讲
如果后面的话我们有时间或者有机会
我们会开开一个高级课程
或者开个专题讲座
跟同学们去分享这些领域里面的
一些前沿的探索
所以呢这里面也跟大家道个歉
就是说虽然我们已经很尽力的往里面塞东西了
但这节课还是有很多的就是计算机图形学啊
就是那个return rendering的东西
我们没有办法放进去
好的那我们就开始今天的课程的正文吧
先跟大家就是因为这是一个新的section的暖场嘛
我们几乎花了15分钟的时间
给大家建立了一个基础的就是render系统
到底是个什么东西
那么好
那我们开始在做rendering之前的话呢
我觉得首先同学们要建立一个概念
就是说这个rendering到底是由哪些要素构成的
那这里面的话呢
我们就那个扩一下我们的这个101的课程
对吧
我这个这一张图是从我们的101课程
练习的课件中扣下来了
然后我跟他讲
我说我要听你的课程
那么这里面的话大家可以看到
就是说哎其实渲染好像也不难
对不对
他就是有很多的顶点
空间上的顶点
然后呢连成了一个个的面
这一面呢经过一个投影矩阵投到我的屏幕上
然后呢我们有个过程叫做rust rizer
Rust ization
那么它就是把这个三角形呢就是rust rise
就官烧光栅化成一个个的小像素点
然后呢在每个小像素点上
我们去找到它的对应的材质啊
它对应的这个纹理啊
就给它就就是给它渲染成各种各样的颜色
你可以考虑光照
可以考虑它本身的花纹
然后渲染出我们最后的效果
所以呢最后我们可以选出我们的这个结果
所以简单来讲的话
就是你看到这里面的话
有成百万的这个顶点啊
三角形啊对吧
有上就是几千万以上的这种像素
有并联
觉得就是10亿级的这种ARU的和text的运算
这就是我们rendering的一个最基础的东西
那这里面的话呢我们可以看到
就是说在绘制的话
它最核心的工作是什么
我们叫做computation对吧
计算机你要去画出一个东西
还要工作
其实这里面我给大家讲个概念啊
就是其实绘制系统对于游戏引擎来讲
就是说我们就做那种躲在像素之后之后的事情
我记得以前在SIGGRAPH上有个section
就讲游戏引擎绘制嘛
在这中间的话呢
我们就会提到一个东西叫做the men and women behind
The pixel
就是躲在像素之后的男人和女人们
为什么呢
因为就是说我们大家看到的那样
一个壮丽的画面
实际上是现代计算机一个一个像素堆起来了
那么这里面的话呢我们的计算第一种是什么呢
比如说最简单的投影和光栅化对吧
这个在101课程中讲的特别的多
就是我们找一个相机位置
然后呢进行它的投影
无论是正交的还是这个那个透视投影
然后呢
我们得到这个屏幕空间上这个三角形之后
我们把它关上化成一个一个的像素
这就是我们的投影
那么投影光栅化之后呢
诶我们就开始对它进行着色
就是绘制
绘制呢
其实这里面我们取一段就是我们看到这个球
对不对
我们取一段最简单的一个叫
就那个他的成它的代码的案例
那证明这里面的话
他会发现它的运算其实也就几种
比如说第一种
我要去从这个这个常量里面取很多的常量
比如说我做个绘制
我需要知道屏幕上有多少长宽
有多少个像素
那我们是要访问一些常数呢对吧
这些常数在每个像素里面我都要去访问它
那我们中间呢会做大量的加减乘除的运算
比如说我们要算一个缝模型的时候
你需要知道说法线在哪里
光线在哪里
我的眼睛在哪里
我就可以算出来说
诶
这个光有百分之多少
会被我这个就是这个这个衰减掉对吧
那么我这个小球上有很多的花纹
那我是不是要把它存到一张这个2D的贴图上
我在那个点把那个贴图上那个颜色取出来
放到一起
这些东西就像炒一盘菜一样的
你用这几种运算
就是说啊数学运算常数的访问变量的访问
再加上这个就是texture的访问的话
你就能得到你想要的结果
那这个事情呢其实听上去很简单
但这里面呢我要跟同学们建立一个概念
就是说其实在绘制中啊
有一个过程
大家可能注意不到
但其实它非常的复杂或者是昂贵
就是什么呢
叫做texture
就是踩踩这个纹理
那为什么这个东西它其实非常的复杂呢
大家想想一下啊
就是这里面给大家讲个概念
就是说啊我们在人身上贴个花纹
比如说我们作业面砖墙
这个砖墙离你很近的时候
你会看到一个一个的像素
对不对
但如果这个砖墙离你非常非常远的时候
其实啊你在屏幕上看到的一个像素
在那个纹理上其实是隔了很多很多的像素的
那这个时候如果我们不去对它进行一个
叫做这个专业的说法叫滤波
做一个低频滤波的话
你当我的这个砖墙由远及近的移动的时候啊
由由近及远的移动的时候
你会看到那个画面一直在抖动
这个东西叫什么呢
叫做走样
我相信很多同学玩游戏的时候
你们会有一个叫图形设置
叫NTL型防走样
对不对
那么如果你的显卡特别好的话
你会把你反走样开的特别高
其实呢这也是一个很重要的反走样的方法
那在纹理上面的话呢
我们实际上每一张贴图我们会存很多很多层
当我作为一个屏幕上一个小小的像素点
我去取一个纹理的时候
实际上我首先我取的位置不一定在那个
就是那个像素点上
所以呢我要取四个点
要对它进行插值
然后呢我还要在两层的放比例上去取
那这里面的话考大家一个数学题啊
我们要做一次纹理采样
我们要访问多少数据
我们要做多少次差值呢
对这个答案是这样的
就是我们要是这个图上已经画的很清楚了
就是如果我们做一个采样
我们要采样八个顶点啊
就八个像素点的数据要做几次差值呢
要错四七次差值
所以大家想想看
就是我取一个最简单的颜色
我的计算机要做这么多的工作
所以这件事情呢
其实也是绘制中的一个很重要的运算
所以这里面的话呢
我们就要隆重推出我们今天的主角了
就是GPU对吧
graphics的这个process unit
那么实际上也就是大家讲的这个显卡
那么显卡这件事情的话呢
是非常了不起的一个发明创造
就像我们第一节课也讲过
就是现代的很多引擎
之所以能够就是啊有突飞猛进的变化
就是因为随着独立的显卡出现
我们可以把这些复杂的运算
用一台更高效的机器进行处理
这样的话我极大的释放了我的这个CPU
同时的话呢我们可以把画面越做越清晰
所以说如果你想成为一个就是游戏引擎的图形
程序员的话
那这是你最好的伙伴
你最好的buddy
包括我们现在游戏引擎里面
很多绘制系统的基础设计的话
它都是基于现代显卡的架构的理解
所以接下来这一趴呢会非常的高能
就是我要跟同学们讲一下
就是我我已经是尽可能的
讲一些比较简单的东西
就帮助同学们建立就是显卡的基础架构
让大家知道
就是当我们架构一个系统的时候
我们需要关注什么
但是呢呃对于就是没有基础的同学呢
稍微有一点点高能啊
反正同学们如果听不懂的话
会会可以告诉我们
我们后面再去看看怎么去补充好
那我们进入一个最基础的硬件的这个漫游概念
那要想理解显卡呢
我觉得首先要建立两个概念
就是叫SMD和SMT
这个听上去是不是很高大上
其实SMD就是这个是我们的老朋友了
大家还记得我们在前面讲过
就是现在CPU里面的话
实际上呢已经广泛地使用了
这个就是要单指令多数据的加减
这个数学运算
简单来讲就是一个四维的向量对吧
就那么当我做一次加法指令的时候
他的XYZW坐标同时在做运算
所以我一个指令能完成四个加法或者四个减法
这个听上去很简单对吧
就是那个在我们的那个
就是很多的高性能运算中
我们会呃
我跟同学讲过
就是如果你们看C加代码
会看到有些叫SSE的这个扩展宏
那实际上就是在调用SMD的这个指令
大家想象一下我们在渲染的时候
是不是有大量的这种
就是这种类似于这样的运算
比如矩阵运算对吧
坐标变换运算
所以SMD就是我们最好的朋友
这个概念非常好理解
而但是呢在现代显卡里面的话呢
我觉得同学们一定要理解
另外一个更有趣的概念
叫做SIMT叫single instruction
Multi threst
就是他的想法呢其实也非常的简单
就是说如果我的一个计算内核
我把它做的很小
但是我可以做很多很多个
我这样的一条指令的时候
我可以在很多很多的盒上同做同样的指令操作
那比如说我假设有100个盒放在那儿
那我一条指令下去
我是不是可以做100个四个数的加减乘除呢
那是不是我的计算效呢
以前是乘了四
我再乘了100
所以那我的比例是不是放大了400倍
其实现代的这个显卡的话
大家如果去看的话
它本质上就是一个我认为是个大蜂巢
就是放了无数个小小的盒
那现在比如像那个NVIDIA的
就N卡的话
一般是放了无数个小库大盒的
后面我们会详细的讲到
但是这个呢实际上就是现代显卡
为什么算力这么强的原因
那么就跟大家讲了基础的概念
就比如说像现在的很多显卡的
好的计算的这个性能
如果我们有一个有个概念叫flops
就是一个浮点运算能力吧
就是那么一秒钟你能完成多少次浮点的计算
那么这个现在的显卡
一般能达到十个以上的TREFLOS
对不对
比如像XBOXX或PS5
但是呢现在的CPU的话呢
一般在很难达到一个turf
它两个数量已经超差距
已经超过了一个数量级
那为什么显卡能够遥遥领先于CPU呢
本质上是显卡耍流氓
就是说CPU很老实对吧
我就是一个人闷头处理所有的事情
但是呢显卡很流氓
就是招了很多小伙伴
虽然每个人能力都不是很强
但是大家一起来协作
所以他的算力非常的快
那为什么要让同学们知道这个SMT这个结构呢
就是说我们在做所有的绘制算法的时候
做所有的运算的时候
都尽可能是用同样的代码
大家让大家一起跑
然后呢每个人分别访问自己的数据
这个时候你可以在显卡上跑起来非常的快
而且是远远远远超过你在CPU上算出来的东西
这个是做图形程序的话
最重要的要掌握的一个概念
那么你有了这个概念的话呢
其实大家就可以窥探一下
就是现代GPU的这个架构了
那这张图就比较高呢
同学们看的是不是觉得很晕啊
密密麻麻的
如果有密集恐惧恐惧症的同学会觉得很难受
其实呢这个图虽然很复杂吧
但是呢我们有一个简单的方法
就是你可以发现啊
其实它的结构是重复的
就比如说这里面我们选用了一个相对简单的
就是那个费米架构
费米架构大概是10年前的
10年前的那个N卡的架构了吧
最新的架构应该是安培最新的哦
是四零系列的话
有可能是那个Hope的架构
那我们先当然他技术原理的差不多吧
那我们就用那个这个费米这个架构来给大家讲
就是一块显卡上
他放了很多的内核
但是呢它分成一组一组的
这每一组叫什么呢
叫做GPC
其实是graphics process cluster
就是一个图形处理集群
然后在这个图形集集群里面的话呢
你可以看到很多的
就是他们叫做那个就是那个string multiprocessor
这个stream multiprocessor里面装了很多的小的块
小内核
一般在N卡上
我们放的是库塔的盒
这个库塔核干什么事情呢
它就做大量大量的数学运算
然后呢这个这样的一个那个string multiprocessor的话
你给他一条指令
这些小孩就哐叽就一下子狂跑起来了
然后在这里面的话呢
他有专门的硬件帮你去处理
他的这个就是各种texture
就是我刚才讲的非常废的纹理采样的工作
包括呢做一些比较复杂的数学运算
比如说啊同学们要有概念
就是当你们将来以后做这个绘制的时候
如果你想在显卡上跑加减乘除没有太大问题
但是如果你要扩一些像什么sign啊
cos啊这些什么这个这个这个三角函数啊
对吧
你可以明白它的运算速度会比较慢
还有专门的SFU帮你去处理这件事
这个讲讲起来就太深了
我们今天不展开
其实大家如果看最新的
比如说安培架构里面的话
这里面会塞什么呢
会塞一个叫tensor CORE
就是这个著名的人工智能的这个
这个这个这个核心还放个什么东西
还放一个叫RT CORE
就是大家喜闻乐见的光追
那其实那里面有个专门的核心去支持这件事情
所以这其实呢就是现代GPU的架构
但同学们怎么去理解这件事情呢
就是我们的很多的运算
这个CPU上都是分到一个个的
这个叫这个string multiprocessor这个单元去处理
那么这里面的话几十个核的
其实他们不仅是并行的处理工作啊
他们还可以互相交换情报
形成这样的一个一个一个协作体
所以呢这里面可以看到他们有shared memory这件事情
如果同学们如果有写过这个叫多
就是那个KROUTINE啊
就是B进化编程的时候
你们就知道说哦
我们的这些CPU之间还可以交换数据的话
我可以做一些非常酷炫的运算了
所以这个是现代GPU最重要的架构
也就是我们几乎所有的运算
都是跑在这样的一个架构上面来
那么这里面的话呢
就是第一个
我们把这个SMT的架构这个概念教给大家
那第二个
我想同学们建立了一个基本概念是什么呢
就是其实啊
我们的数据在这个计算机里面流动的时候
是有成本的
就是从我们计算机诞生开始的时候
我们用的是什么架构呢
这个有一个很著名的学术名词叫冯诺依曼架构
冯诺依曼架构它的核心是什么呢
就是把计算和数据分开
这个架构非常好
会让硬件设计变得非常的简简单
对不对
当然其实现在有一些很前沿的研究
就是想打破这个架构
那我们今天不展开啊
那么这个架构所带来最大的问题是什么
就是我每一个计算我可能需要去找数据
后来大家发现就是找数数据
这件事情是特别特别慢
而且数据呢在不同不同的计算单元中
搬来搬去也是非常慢
我们举个例子啊
就比如说在这个
就是大家刚才还记得我们一开始的那个南桥
北桥嘛对吧
那个北桥上面我们放了一个这个CPU
这边放了一个显卡
但CPU呢它里面装的是一个主主内存
然后这里面的数据
如果我把它上传到我们的显卡的显存上的话
这个速度是非常慢的
而且呢还有一点是什么呢
就是说我们GPU不是算的非常的快吗
显卡算的非常的快
但是呢大家想想看我的一个计算
如果我先从CPU准备好
交给显卡去算
显卡算好
我把它的数据读回来
CPU再基于你对这个计算的结果再做一些判断
然后再告诉CPU怎么绘制的话
这个我们叫做这个数据的DK force吧
那实际上会有一个非常严重的问题
什么问题呢
就是说啊因为在现代引擎架构中啊
一般绘制和逻辑是不同步的
但是你如果有一部绘制运算
需要等着他们来回去back force的话
实际上你很可能会导致就是半真到一帧的
我们叫做这个latency
那整个画面就是我们经常会看见
就是这个逻辑和画面不同步
有的时候可能会因为这件事情会导致
所以呢在游戏引擎的绘制系统架构中
我们有一个原则
就是我们尽可能把数据单向传输
就是CPU送到显卡就完事了
然后呢尽可能的不要从显卡里面读数据
这也是现代计算机结构
导致了我们的设计上的一个要点
那么第三件事情呢
我希望同学们对硬件掌握的建
建立的概念是什么呢
就是cash叫缓存
那么其实cash这件事情是对现代计算的性能
影响是非常非常大的
可能远远超过大家的想象
我给大家建立一个基本的概念吧
就是说呃大家知道就是我们在CPU上
现在CPU啊
如果我们去做一次加减乘除
可能一个clock就做完了
对不对
但是如果这个时候比如说我说A加B
但是A我找不到了
A在我的内存上
大家写代码的时候
是不是觉得就是内存上放数据
对不对
但这个时候实际上
如果CPU发现不在自己的缓存里面
我需要去内存去找内存已经非常快了
对不对
实际上它要等100多个时钟周期
也就有那个时间
我已经做了几十个上百个运算走了
所以这就是为什么我在上一节课给大家讲的
就是说数据一定要放在一起对吧
其实它就是为了cash去做这样的准备
这件事情呢在我们的图形
在我们的显存上是非常非常重要的
那包括就是说比如说有些数据过大了之后
它也会导致这个cash很难背这个利用好
所以呢这里面两个概念
就是当我做每次计算的时候
如果A恰好数据都在我的缓存上
我们叫做什么呢
叫做cash hit
就是我们的缓存被命中了
那么如果呢这个时候我数据不在缓存中
我们叫什么呢
叫cash miss
数据就是就我要等很久
所以你很多时候做这个计算机图形学的啊
就是做那个游戏引擎的绘制的时候
如果你的这些纹理这些计算没做好
老师让计算机产生catch miss的时候
它的效率就直接下降了
所以呢这节课呢
我们高能的部分基本上快结束了
但是呢我跟大家去讲一下
就是如果大家以后有机会进入到这个就是啊
图形程序
这个对于我们的这个就是游戏引擎的话
你会学会很多黑化
现在互联网黑话呀
你比如说这个au bound对吧
就是这个这个就是呃我的数学计算太多了
导致的就是说我其他的纹理采样什么都来得及
但是呢就是等你的数学运算结果
比如说像favorite bt
就是说我所有的运算都算完了
但是呢我写到那个缓存
你的速度太慢了
结果就是一直要等大家都堵在那了
其实你会发现它的整个现代的计算机
它就是一个流水线
只要有一个环节它没有平衡好
它一旦卡住了
你其他东西优化的再快
它也会被卡住
所以棒的这个词是一个最常用的一个黑化
所以但是今天呢我不展开
因为这个太深了
就是也不
或者说以后大家再进入到这个
就是游戏引擎开发中间的话
你们都会遇到
所以这些东西其实让大家深度的理解了
就是现在的游戏
特别是呃就是非常复杂的顶级游戏的话
他再去做渲染系统的设计的时候
是会非常关注这个对GPU的使用和利用的
那么其实呢这里面我要跟同学们讲一下
就是其实硬件的结构一直在变对吧
那么最像从最早的DX11时代
大概差不多10年前吧
我们看到的就是可以做更细分曲面的
更更加灵活的SHADER
包括可以更通用的计算SHADER
到今天的话
我们看到了就是更容易去处理的这种mesh shader
这些结构一直在变
那么包括呢就是这里面
我们可以在之前经常跟同学们讲的
就是说当我从PC走向了主机之后
那主机的架构又不一样
因为主机的话它是一个叫u ma
就是它的内存全部是共享的这样的一个架构
那你的这个引擎架构又会不一样
那么还有一个很著名的
就是这个大家现在天天见到的什么叫手游
手游是跑到哪了
是跑在移动端
对不对
但在移动端上的话呢
他考虑到这个就是功耗
考虑到它的处理芯片的这个能力
因为这个就是说其实访问数据是最昂贵的
我一直讲过嘛
所以呢他们就develop的这个tale base renderry对吧
就是我们你看着手机上一个
比如说1080P或者更高清的4K的画面
实际上它是一小块一小块的渲染出来的
那这些东西的话呢
其实你会发现我们所有的引擎架构都适合
硬件的架构息息相关的
所以同学们在学渲染之前的话
我是特别特别希望同学们能够先去了解一下
这个显卡到底是怎么工作的
你理解了显卡是怎么工作的话
你对这种各种渲染的这个引擎算法
就有更深的理解
所以这1part呢是相对比较高的
同学们听不懂没有关系
建立一个基础概念就可以了
那么同学们会说诶
那如果我不是做引擎的
我需要了解这些东西吗
我个人认为的哈
如果你是做游戏开发
如果你是做有特别是游戏的这个art
就是艺术家的话
我觉得多少掌握这些概念还是有好处的
为什么呢
因为就是说当你去设计你的游戏的玩法的时候
你会知道硬件在什么地方会卡我们
所以我们不会把这个场景做得无限的复杂
我能更专注于在我的玩法上面
好的高能的部分基本上讲完了
那接下来呢就我们把难度下降一点
给同学们讲一讲
就是那好了
我们已经知道这个显卡是怎么做出来了
那现在可以让我去做一个简单的绘制了吧
那这个地方的话呢其实并不是特别的难
比如说我们打开一个游戏吧
我们看到的是什么
在上一节课我们讲的就是
这个世界里面大部分东西都是叫game object
对不对
那么这些所有的game object的话呢
就是构建了这个世界
但是上节课我没有跟他讲的
是说我们对游戏里面的每一个物体
有很多的描述
比如说它是一辆车
它是一个飞机对吧
它可以有血量
它可以有各种各样的行为
但是同学们意识到这里面所有的东西
它只是一个逻辑的描述
这个东西它其实是绘制不了的
所以这里面的话呢我们需要区分一个概念
就是说就是一个逻辑上表达的
这样的一个游戏对象
和你真实可以绘制的东西是两个东西
所以那天我们在讲到这个组件的时候
会讲到有一个component叫什么
mesh component对吧
实际上这个名词呢
在不同的引擎里面有很多的变化
有的人叫做mesh component的
有的人叫做skin mesh component
比如说skin mesh component
就是说假设这个mesh它是有骨骼的
可以一直去变形
比如说我们做一个角色的时候
他可以动来动去
但是它的底层理念是大同小异的
那我们在这个component里面
存了一个很神奇的东西
我们一般在行业里叫什么呢
叫做RENDERABLE
RENDERABLE是什么呢
就是可绘制的东西
就是我拿到了这个RENDERABLE这个物体
我就能把它绘制出来了
所以说这是我们这个绘制系统的
核心的数据对象
那么一个RENDERABLE怎么来了
那我们首先看这个物体本身吧
那比如说以我们的这个小明
想做的这个
超越2042的现代战争游戏的为为例
它请了一个艺术家
做了这样的一个很酷的视频的角色
他就会发现诶
这个家伙身上好像首先有很多的网格mesh对吧
就是它的几何形体
比如他的头盔
他的枪很帅
然后呢每一个mesh呢上面有各种各样的材质
比如说有的像布
有的像那个金属对吧
有的像皮肤
然后呢这些材质上面呢还有很多的花纹
所以我们会展现出各种texture
但其实还有比如说它的normal对吧
normal就是说诶更细的
你没有办法用mesh表达的这些细节
我们用normal去表达
好像你看这些东西是不是可以绘制的东西
这就是我们RENDERABLE的最简单的一个building block
但实际上RENDERABLE在现代游戏引擎中
比这个更复杂
但是这些是最基础的一个概念
那我们再top down一下
就是说那首先咱mesh在我们的计算机引擎里面
游戏引擎里怎么表达呢
就是说如果大家不去做引擎的话
这些数据你是不用关注的
就比如说大家想象一个
我从那个max用一个导入器导进来了
诶这个模型我在那个unity你就能看见了
对不对
其实这里面我们首先要定义一种叫做mesh
Primitive
对吧
这个primitive这个词呢
其实有的时候会跟几何会通用
但我们这边就是简单的叫max primitive
那最简单的表达一个目的是什么哦
我们有很多的顶点
顶点上呢有很多的数据
比如说顶点的到底在哪里
这是一个数据
对不对
还有什么呢
它的法向朝向
它就是它这个面是这个顶点是朝向哪的
还有一个是什么呢
比如说它的UV啊
还有其他一些各种各样的属性
然后每三个顶点我们放在一起
是不是就变成了一个三角形
那我们把这些三角形放在一起
就形成了这样的一个外观
这个形状
当然了
这种数据存储方式是一种很笨的方式
实际上同学们如果写过这个
open gl和direct的代码的话
最基础的同学代码就知道
我们会把数据用index data和vertex data去定义
什么意思呢
就是说我们把所有的顶点放在一起
三角形呢不会再把顶点数据再存一遍
我只存这个顶点的索引值
那为什么这么沉呢
其实道理非常简单
就是说我们打开一个真实的模型的话
你会发现诶
他很多顶点是被很多个三角形共用的
实际上的话呢大家如果用数学算一下
就是很多模型中
大概顶点的数量只有三角形的数量的一半
而一个三角形里面又有三个顶点
所以说你用这种index的方法的话呢
理论上它的计算存储量可以节约六倍以上
因为顶点的数据很费
它要存这个三个float的
它的空间位置对吧
三个float
它的那个法向可以不需要三个float层了
比如说还有一大堆的UV这些数据
所以的话呢就是说这是在实战的系统中
一般采用的方法
这个东西是不是很好理解对吧
那么包括的话呢
就是呃这里面还有一些简单的概念呢
比如说同学们想一下
如果我把顶点存在一起
我可不可以不需要index buffer呢
实际上是可以的
比如说大家知道有一种概念叫triangle strip
就是说呃在我们的这个
就是他同学们小时候有没有做过
叫一笔画的问题
就是我假设一个复杂的网络
我用一一帧一笔把它所有的边全部勾勒出来
如果我所有的勾勒的过程的话
都符合一个个的三角形的话
其实我可以每三个顶点
每就是D12
比如说我们顶点数是01234567
2012是一个三角形
123又是个三角形
这个234又是个三角形
这样的话呢我不用再单独的存储它的index buffer
实际上呢它也能表达一个mesh
而且呢这样的表达还有一个很大的好处
是什么呢
刚才我们在前面讲这个GPU的架构的时候
想到一个很重要的东西
叫什么叫做cash缓存
如果我们每个三角形绘制的时候
对顶点数据的访问都是这样顺序的话
是不是对缓存来讲最friendly
所以在早期的这个这个游戏引擎里面的话
我们会尽可能的想办法把一些模型变成这个
Triangle strip
也是这个道理
但是呢现在游戏呢一般比较强大
所以我们也不太会特别强调这件事情
那这里面的话呢我跟同学们讲一个概念
就是这是我在最早做从
因为我以前是学计算机图形学嘛
当我开始做游戏引擎的时候
我当时就很晕
我说为什么每个顶点都要从一个法向
这里面一个很简单的一个数学知识
就是说呃我们每个三角形可以算出它的朝向
对不对
那用邻近的几个三角形就可以average出来
就可以平均化出来
我的顶点朝向
这个呢对于大部分情况下都是对的
但是呢一旦你的表面它是有这个硬表面
就是有一条折线的时候
你会发现两个顶点的位置是重合的
但是呢它的法向完全不一样
这里面举个例子就是正方形的Q
所以同学们在一开始入行
去写游戏引擎的绘制系统的时候
在你定义你的顶点数据的时候
一定要给每个顶点单独定义它的法向方向
这里面也是我以前踩过的坑
所以当我今天在准备这个课件的时候
我就特别想把我这个当年犯的错误
跟大家去分享一下
当然我相信我们的小伙伴可能比我聪明的多
也许说这么简单的问题
我怎么会不知道呢
唉那这就是我们的这个max形状数据
那么另外一个数据呢
就是刚才已经讲的就是材质对吧
我做出了他的样子
那我就说这东西看起来像石头呢
还是像金属呢
还是像布呢
还是像漂亮的塑料呢
其实材质系统啊
它非常来自于我们真实的生活
你会发现早期的材质系统的表达
是非常非常接近于我们在物理世界
对东西的感知
那么最早的这个这个比如像逢魔型的时候
大家就会说塑料它的反射应该是什么样子的
这个金属应该是什么样子对吧
石头那个非金属应该是什么样子的
但是的话呢就是说这些材质系统的话呢
其实大家讲一个小小的知识
就是在后面我们讲到物理的时候
其实还有另外一种材质叫physics material
它其实跟这个东西呢很容易混到一起
那个东西更多的表达的是这个东西
它的摩擦系数对吧
它的这个你撞上去之后
它的弹性反弹力是多少
和这个概念
其实你你有时候会觉得他们相近
但但是在现代引擎中的话呢
一般我们在绘制系统中定义的只是视觉材质
而物理材质呢我们会单独的去定义它
那么材质系统呢其实经过了这么多年的发展
从图形学中最经典的
比如说缝模型对吧
大家最著名的缝模型
到现在的
就是我们在下一节课会给大家详细讲的
这个基于物理的
就是physics based rendering
基于物理的PV2模型对吧
包括一些特殊的效果
比如说我们讲的这个半透明的3S材质
其实我们在这个行业里面
已经积累了一大批非常优秀的这个材质模型
那么有了这些材质模型对吧
然后呢
接下来我们需要的是什么呢
就是这个需要纹理
其实啊在表达一个材质的时候
文理扮演了非常非常重要的作用
其实现在的这个就是计算机那个图形学里面
在我们的游戏引擎里面
其实很多时候材质你觉得它是像金属
还是像一个这个这个这个生锈的非金属表面
并不是由材质的参数决定的
很多时候是由它的纹理决定的
在这个里面大家看到这个生锈的铁球
你怎么区分那个光滑的金属表面
和那个生锈的非金属表面
那个就是那种他其实也算金属
但是你感觉像是石头或者什么东西在表面的话
实际上是通过这些纹理
比如roughness这样的纹理来区分的
所以纹理呢也是材质非常重要的一种表达方式
那最后一个呢就是大家会忽略掉的
就是是不是我们有了这个材质的表达
我们有了文理
有了mesh
我就能够绘制出我的东西呢
这里面有一个无名英雄叫做SHADER
Shader
其实是在游戏引擎中啊
一个非常奇葩的一个存在
因为我们做引擎的
一般会区分什么叫做数据对吧
就比如说我们做或者叫ASA的资产
我做的各种各样的模型是资产
对不对
然后呢什么东西是什么呢
叫source code
是我写出的程序员写出的源码
一般艺术家设计师你们碰数据
程序员碰源码
但是SHADER呢是一个很神奇的存在
它首先肯定是源码
对不对
我们是要用大量的代码写出来
我这个怎么去表达这些材质
但是呢他在游戏引擎中又会当成数据来处理
就是当我去绘制每一个东西的时候
我告诉现在的显卡说啊我要画一个球
OK这个球上贴了一个虎皮花纹
这个时候你还要给他一小段代码
我们一般叫一个block
就是一个二进制的一个数据块
这是我的一个编译好的一个SHADER代码
你说你就用这个程序去把这些元素合到一起
绘制成我要的东西
那么SHADER其实变化也非常大
因为从固定的这个著名的材质模型
包括现在在现代引擎中
大家可能听说过一个概念
叫做shader graph
shader graph是什么东西呢
就是当艺术家想表达各种各样的材质的时候
它就像搭积木一样的
把各种元素组再按自己的方法进行组合
那它组合完之后呢
实际上它会生成一个一个不同的SHADER的代码
而这个设置代码的话呢
它又会编译成一个数据
这些数据呢又会和这些mesh存储在一起
然后呢让我们去形成多种多样的游戏世界
所以SHADER也就是着色器的代码
它也是一种关键的RENDERABLE的数据
那好了
我们有了这样的一个东西的话
那我们就可以在引擎中绘制东西了
因为我们有了我们就知道绘制东西
它有网格
我们有这个啊材质材质里面最多的数据是什么
是纹理
然后呢还要配上一小段的这个shader code
我们就可以绘制一个东西
那这个时候呢我们开始绘制其实非常简单
就像我们在101课程里面会讲到
说我们先做个投影变化嘛
那就就是首先的话呢我把物体放在这儿对吧
我首先把它每个物体做好的时候
它在自身的这个坐标系
我们要把它乘上一个叫模型矩阵
把它从自身的坐标系移到一个世界坐标系里面
然后呢一到世界坐标系的时候
这时候我确定一个相机的位置
我们用一个叫view matrix把它投影到相机坐标系
然后呢相机呢我们再去对他进行正交
或者是这个这个这个这个透视投影
把它变成我们在这个屏幕坐标系里的东西
这个课程呢在这里面我们就不展开了
因为这是大家如果去学open g2
如果是学过101的课程
这都是我们绘制的一个基础的东西
这一趴很简单
对不对
接下来我们就开始很愉快的
按照上一章节讲的东西
我先把你的vertex buffer
Index buffer
就是这个mesh的东西我提交上去对吧
然后呢我把你的材质参数提交上去
我把一个个的这个texture提交上去
给我们的显卡
然后呢我再给你一小段代码
说显卡你看到的每一个顶点
每个像素你就这么执行就对了
好显卡就很愉快地跑完
这个时候就把我们的这个物体
真的就绘制出来了
对不对
这就是这个时候就完成了
从一个抽象的逻辑上的游戏对象
变成了一个RENDERABLE可绘制的东西
但这样位置对不对呢
其实我相信聪明的同学很快就会发现有问题
比如像我们的图片的这个
这个就是啊右边的这个这个角色
你会发现诶他不是这个人身上有很多的材质吗
如果我只是简单地这样去写的话
一个物体我如果只设它一个材质对吧
一个纹理的一套纹理的话
他好像就画错了
所以呢那我身上有那么多材质
这个数据我怎么去整理呢
所以这里面我们想引入一个
就是说这个非常重要的一个概念叫做SUMESH
就是其实在现代游戏引擎中啊
我们对于一个一个GO一个对象的话
它的一个所有的mesh
一个mesh我们会根据他身上用的材质不同
把它切换成很多的smash
就英文叫做SUMESH
然后呢每个3mesh的话呢会对应于自己的材质
自己的纹理和自己的这个shader code是什么样的
但是呢我们一般会把它的顶点啊
把他的这个三角形呢
全部放到一个大的这个buffer里面去
所以每个some mesh呢你只需要存一个offset
就是说哎我的index buffer从哪个点到哪个点去offset
就可以了
同学们能想象这个结构吗
也就是说我们把整个网格放成一个大的
一个一个一个铺一个buffer
但是呢我每个smash呢只用了buffer中间的一小段
这样的话我就知道了
这个这个这从从这个起点到端点之间的
这些三角形
我需要设置成什么样的材质
什么样的SHADER
什么样的texture来绘制它
所以呢some mesh的概念
其实是现在引擎里面特别常用的概念
如果大家打开
比如说像虚幻引擎啊
像很多引擎你们都会看到类似的这种结构
可能名字叫的不一样
但基本逻辑是这样的
那这个时候
如果我们这样再去做这个游戏引擎的话
你会发现一个非常有意思的事情
就是当我去绘制很多很多东西的时候
我如果每一个机油
我们都去存储它的整个这一套
从这个mesh到some mesh
到它的各种各样的材质
到他各种各样的这个SHADER
各种样的texture的话
这个数据量会不会非常的大
对不对
而且大家如果仔细观察
你会发现这里面很多的mesh
甚至是有些贴图
甚至是SHADER
它都是一样的
那我们怎么样子节约它的空间呢
所以在现在游戏引擎中呢
我们一般的做法是会建立一个铺
我们把所有的mesh放到一起
形成了一个mesh的P
我们把所有的texture也放在一起
比如说我们作为一个一个人吧
他身上很多的纹理
其实在在其他人身上可能会共用的对吧
特别是SHADER
比如说如果大家用的都是PP2的话
那我们的SHADER是不是长得一模一样
我假设有1000个这样的对象
我是不是只需要存一份
所以SHADER我也是放在一个铺了
那这样的话当我绘制一个场景
各种各样的这个角色
各种小兵的时候
你会发现它只是通过一个指引
指向了各自所需要的我的材质啊
我的mesh的网格
这个呢是一个非常经典的游戏引擎架构
所以同学们如果你们加自己的游戏引擎的话呢
就记住两点
第一我要去通过sam mesh把每个对象
每个物体
每个mesh按照这个材质进行切换
但是切分好之后呢
我们要对把相同的材质全部归类到一起
有相同的纹理归类到一起
用一个大的push管理
然后呢相同的mesh也放到一起
也是用一个大库去管理
到时候我去绘制每一个物体的时候
我就找它相应的对应就好了
这样我存储空间是最小的
那这里面其实就引入了这个游戏引擎架构里面
一个很经典的概念
我们叫做instantly instances的意思是什么
意思叫实例化
就是刚才我们讲的那些数据啊
它都是它的定义
就是我定义了一个小屏
他的rainbow应该长什么样子对吧
但是呢
当我在屏幕上画了这个几千个小兵的时候
那其实每一个小兵只是那个数据的一个实例
其实这个概念啊
在游戏引擎的设计中是从头贯贯彻到尾的
不仅是在绘制这一趴
其实在我们做游戏逻辑啊
游戏的这种场景物的管理啊等等
都是有这个叫object definition
object instance这个概念
所以的话呢因此这个词同学们一定要牢记于心
当你做引擎的时候
一定要区分的非常清楚
就是这个数据是我的定义对吧
那这个数据呢是我的实力
一般来讲我数据创建了实力之后
还可以再加一点点的变化
但这个讲起来就比较复杂了
今天我就不展开
所以讲到这一趴的话呢
我觉得同学们基本上已经知道说
我怎么样的去构建一个可以绘制的
一个有很多很多物体的一个游戏世界
那这里面我们就往前再走一点点
就是说哎我们刚才讲的GPU啊
它其实有个有个特点
就是它特别懒
就是你给他设置了一个参数
你每次去改变他的时候
他都很烦
他说啊你要改我的参数了
你是不是要改这个贴图啊
你要给我换SHADER扣的
大家想到那个刚才那个那个那个那个string
multiprocessor sm那个结构对吧
你每次去换他的那些东西的时候
是不是那32小时都说啊
那我们停下来吧
等你把这个数据换好
我再去运转吧
其实在GPU上
在显卡上每一次换这个数据他都很烦
他都觉得你很慢诶
这个时候呢聪明的小伙伴们就会想到一个办法
那我这样好不好
我们把这个场景里不是有很多的物体吗
比如像这个里面
你看了这么多的这个地上的那个碎木头
它其实都是同一个材质对吧
一个材质它就有相相相同的参数
相同的纹理诶
我把整个场景的物体按照你的材质进行排序
那么把相同材质的东西国服到一起去
我设置一次材质
然后呢我就绘制这一个月的sub mesh
那这个速度是不是会更快呢
实际上你去算它的计算量好像是一样的
但是呢你交给显卡的时候
这样速度确实是真的会变快
也就是包括在我们以后
如果有机会跟同学们讲
就是现代的这个一些
比如像DX12
像VULKAN的它的架构的话
实际上它会把对CPU的状态设置
专门抽象成一个就是render state object对吧
一个就是他每个沃肯和那个都不太一样
它命名
不然它的基础逻辑就是说我对显卡的状态设置
实际上是预先非运好的
一次性是好
尽量不要动
然后再做一大堆的预算
所以呢你这个绘制的时候可以用材质进行排序
把同样的smash归集在一起
那今天的话呢还可以
这其实在现代的游戏中的话呢
不只是这一步
实际上我们会发现很多的这个子物体啊
它其实是一模一样的
这些物体的话
实际上我把它依次的去绘制
设置VBIB也是很浪费的
所以我们实际上现在用现在的计算SHADER
或者是其他SHADER的能力的话
可以一个桌括设置一次
VBIB和它绘制的一堆位移的数据
也是一张就是一列数据放进去之后
我一下子一个桌括就是一次绘制指令
可以把几百个上千个东西全部创建出来
这个东西呢就是GPU based bachelor
rendering的这样的一个思想
这个地方我们在今天课上不展开
但同学们要建立这个概念
就是我最后跟同学总结
就是说现在的游戏引擎架构中的话
我们会尽可能的把绘制运算交给GPU来运算
而不是用CPU运算
那么这个东西呢
大家想象一下什么地方特别有用
比如说我们要绘制大量的树啊
草啊对吧
看起来差不多
但是我一下载要绘制这个几百米开外
甚至上上公里的这样的东西的话
这个东西其实非常的有用
所以大家理解了
就是我们把一个对象怎么chop成材质
some mesh之后
那你这个时候就可以做很多
很有意思的这个优化了
但最基础的概念还是mesh
Some mesh
这是我们的基础概念
那有了这样一个东西之后呢
其实我们基本上就开始可以作为绘制
一个小小的游戏场景了
但这样的绘制它是不是高效的呢
实际上并不高效
为什么呢
大家知道我们的事件锥对吧
我们的世界锥实际上是一个锥形的东西
在你任何时候我们去看这个世界的时候
其实其他部分的东西我们是看不见的
比如在这里面案例里面
小明做的这个战争游戏的话
当它的相机开始在移动的时候
你会发现
其实七八十%以上的空间我们是看不见的
那那你们的物体啊
对象啊
粒子效果
我们是不是都不需要绘制
包括地形
所以呢viewer就是那个visibility colin
就可见性裁剪
是游戏的绘制系统的一个
最基础的一个底层系统
这个东西的话怎么去做
大家还记得我们在上一节课的时候讲过
就是这个我们这个每一个物体它都有个包围盒
对不对
那我们这个包围盒呢
当我们给一个四面
就是四棱锥的这样一个view frustrand的话
你是不是可以去判断说做个最简单的数学运算
就知道说哎
我这个包围盒是不是在这个事件吹里面
这个其实就是卡林的一个最基础的一个思想
那么这里面的话
我想给同学们讲一下
这个包围盒的一些数学概念
其实啊在游戏的这个这个这个体系里面
有性引擎的体系里面
包围盒是一个非常重要的概念
基本上不仅是在绘制
包括在AI逻辑物理
我们都要用到包盒
那包围盒呢其实有很多种方法
他基本上从这个最简单的
比如说我把这个物体上面画一个球
把这个人装在这个最紧的这个球里面
这叫什么bounding sphere对吧
就是包围的这个叫包围球吧
那么呢还有一种呢更常用的我们叫做AABB
什么叫AABB呢
就是这个access line bounding box
就是说跟各个轴对称的包围和轴是什么呢
就是我们在我们游戏世界里构建的XYZ空间
因为它所有的东西啊都是轴对称的
你只要存两个顶点
就是端点
两个端点
你就可以把这个一个一个a b box就能构建处理
而且它的计算的效率也是最高的
然后呢他要把仅次于球包围
球应该是最高的
然后呢在后面的话呢
我们有的时候包围盒
如果是贴着这个物体去走的话
那我们叫什么呢
叫object o b b就是object的那个BINBOX
那么还有呢就是用凸包CONVEHALL
就是凸包
凸包呢在很多物理运算中
是特别常用的一个概念
所以其实呢无论我们在做visibility
还是做游戏引擎的其他运算的时候
我们对很多物体的表达
因为一个物体的形状是不是非常的复杂
比如说一个角色
他是几万个面
我不可能跟这个几万个面进行一计算对吧
那我就用一个包围盒大致表征你占领的地方
然后我判断说我这时候子弹能不能打中你
我这时候能不能看见你
所以包围盒是很多计算的基础
那有了这样一个包围盒的话
我们依次计算
实际上就能做卡点
但这个效率大家知道一定是不高的
那我们在上一节课你们讲了什么诶
我们对这个空间里的物体进行各种各样的划分
那么最比较经典的
比如说像四叉树这样的划分
对不对
那么还有呢比如说叫我们叫做上节课
教大家一个概念叫BVH叫bounding box
Bounding volutarchy
对吧
就是把这个绑定涡轮133
就像是这个这个这个这个树状结构的往上顶
那这样的好处
就是当我去做一个卡林预算的时候
我可以从上到下一层层去问
比如说当我这几十个物体变成一个节点
我说哎你这个最大的包和我是不是能看得见
如果我看不见算了
你们这几十个物体我就不用了
不用画了
对不对
但如果我能看见你
然后继续问说你是里面有没有更精细的划分呢
如果有我在一直问到你的业界里
我就知道哪些物体可见了
那么它的计算复杂度就会下降非常非常的多
那么其实呢就是在现代的这个游戏里面的话呢
BBH用的是蛮多的
因为这个算法其实非常简单
也不是最高效的算法
那为什么他用的特别多呢
因为现在游戏里面他动的东西很多
就是很就像刚才我们讲的那个
小明要做的那个战争
游戏里面很多小兵会跑来跑去
对不对
那这里面就有一个很复杂的问题了
就是我的这个b vex
就是这个树状结构构建好的时候
当我的这些节点发生变动的时候
那我在构建它的成本要尽可能的低
不能每一次你虽然去做这个卡点的
速度是非常的快
但是每次我构建那个树状结构花的时间最久
所以呢BVH在这一点上是有很多的优势的
所以那个在现在游戏引擎中的话
BVH用的是蛮多的
特别是动态的东西
特别多的东西
那么关于这个visibility ci呢
我有一个算法也特别想跟同学
就是其实呢不止于这一种算法
其实有很多很多的算法
那么这里面的话呢
我只想再讲一个非常有意思的一个一个算法
这其实是一个思想
这个叫p vs
这个思想呢就是这个啊
就是那个potential visibility set
这个思想呢就是我们一直崇拜的john kmark
就是游戏引擎行业的支付
也是我们的大神
当年他在做这个早期的FPS
我我忘了是doom还是quick的时候
他突然觉得哎呀
这个我们的机器性能那么差对吧
我在一个小房间打来打去
我把那么多房间的东西都化了
这是不是很亏呢
他就想到了一个办法是什么
这个方法其实很简单了
就是说我先用BSP啊
这个讲起来有点专业了
就是说简单来讲
就是我把这个空间分成了一个个的小的格子
一个小方块
每个方块之间呢通过一个叫做pal
就是大家如果玩过那个威慑的游戏叫pal的话
就知道
但是两个空间之间连接的窗口对吧
大家想象一下
比如说在一个建筑物里面的房子
是不是都通过门啊
窗啊连接在一起
那好了呀
我站在一个房间里面
我能假设是一栋楼啊
111个
比如说我们豪华的大平层里面有几十个房子
那你在每个房子的时候
这个房子的门你能看过去
能看到其他几个房子
其实是不是固定的
对不对
所以PVS的想法呢非常的淳朴
就是你在每一个房子的时候
你通过他的门或者是窗
你最多能看见哪几个其他的房间
比如说我们假设给每个房间有编号
1234567
比如说你站在那边的7号房间
你发现你最多的只能看到就是123对吧
6123这三四个房间
那就意味着就是说当我站在7号房间的时候
我只需要渲染6123房间里的
无论这个房间本身
还有你们的物体
这个想法是不是非常的简单
straight forward这个想法呢确实是非常的简单
而且非常的直觉
但是呢他执行的效率非常的高
那么实际上呢虽然我这个原理讲起来非常简单
但是PVS的计算包括对空间的划分
partition的算法其实还是蛮复杂的
如果大家有兴趣的话
可以去看一看
去写一写
这是一个非常好的
大家的这个数学和编程能力训练的一个东西
那为什么我会在这个就是visibility count里面
一定要讲这个PVS呢
实际上这是现代游戏啊
其实据我所知
就是真的全面的用p vs做卡林的kiss
好像已经没有那么多了
但是这个思想其实非常的有用
为什么呢
比如说呃我们做一个单机游戏
大家很多小伙伴是不是喜欢玩
主机上的3A大作
对不对
那3A大作里面的话呢
我现在是在上节课讲过
就是我们很多时候设计一个关卡
它其实是个linear线性的
虽然你觉得你是在开放世界
但实际上你走的都是在我设定好的
各个叫我们叫做创始里面好
我们假设把这个游戏玩家能经过的世界
分成一个个叫zone
这个zone是不是像PV里面一个个的小房间
那每个字之间是不是有一个峡峡谷
有个关口
有的时候甚至是一道门挡住了
那我在每一个zone里面的话
我是不是就知道说你能看见其他几个Z
那这件事情除了做visibility还有什么好处呢
实际上是资源的加载
就同学们玩一个游戏的时候
我不知道大家有没有注意到
就是当你闯关打过了一个boss之后
你通过一道门的时候
有的引擎如果做的不好
你发现诶他好像在夹杂了一小会儿
这是为什么呢
就是因为哦你换了一个zone了
你需要你这时候能看见的东西
特别是有些远处的zone
他这时候被加载上来了
所以PVS的算法的话呢
虽然呃我们认为就是在做visibility上面的话
已经没有像以前那么火了
但是呢这个思想其实非常的有用
就是说帮助我们进行各种资源的调度
所以我也希望同学们
就也要了解这样的一个思想
但实际上我讲的这两个算法
都是非常经典的算法
就像我在前面跟同学们讲过
就是说游戏引擎的渲染系统
它是一个高度practical的一个工程事件
随着现在的硬件的性能发生了
突飞猛进的一个变化
实际上越来越多的卡里
已经不再是
用刚才我讲的那些很精巧的算法来解决了
实际上就是用这个GPU就可以做掉
比如说一个很著名的叫accution query
什么意思呢
就是说我把很多物体扔给显卡
显卡后来反反馈给我一个叫比特瑞
就是一群零一构成的一个一个一串数组
就是说这个第一号物体可见就是一
如果第2号物体不可见
就是零
我一看我就知道这个东西可见内容不可见
因为显卡它是B型
它算起来非常的快
那包括呢就是像view flashcaring的话
我们现在可以很粗暴地把这些
帮你box直接扔过去
然后呢让显卡给我算完
其实速度也不会太慢
当然如果你想精彩一点
你可以用这个
就是说显卡的这个这个
这个就是你你也在显卡上构建一个
hierarchy的数据结构
这个其实用现在的computer or也并不是特别的难
所以我这里面为什么跟同学们一定要讲GPU
base卡林呢
因为这其实如果大家真的走上了工作岗位
真的在做现在的游戏的这个开发的时候
千万不要用老的算法去限制你的想法
一定要理解说能在硬件上做的事情
我一定做完
那这里面我跟同学在讲另外一个概念
就是啊HZ的概念
或者叫early z的概念
什么意思呢
就是说其实显卡有个很聪明的能力
就是说当我发现我要绘制的一个像素
一般一般来讲我们在绘制的时候
像素就是因为像素数量特别多嘛
比如说这都是几千万以上的像素点
每一帧
那我发现这个像素呢
其实已经被别的东西挡住了
我就不会它了
那其实呢一个最简单的思想
就是说我先把场景绘制一遍
但我什么渲染都不做
只是把它的深度绘制出来
就是这边大家看到这个黑白的这个图
白的就离我近一点
黑的就离我远点
但实际上在GPU上存储的数据是反的
那这个时候如果我在绘制任何一个东西
只要它比它那个就是在后面的话
我整个绘制可以跳掉了
甚至是整个物体都可以跳掉
这个呢就是一个非常淳朴的early z的思想呢
包括现在有些更复杂的
比如说基于这种hierarchy的方法
去做这个Z的处理
但是呢他的整个思想我认为是大同小异的
就是说都是用GPU高速的并行化能力
然后呢加上这个就是我能够尽可能快的
廉廉价的成本形成一群遮挡物的深度图
然后呢把很多的东西能扔掉
尽可能扔掉这件事情
对于那种就是说非常复杂的这种场景很有用
比如说你进入到一个房间的时候
你可以发现啊
就是这个世界的99%以上你都不见了
其实你就关注在这个房间里面这些人
所以这个当我们在做游戏引擎设计的时候
非常在意这些东西
所以这就是calling的最核心的思想
那有了这些东西之后呢
我们基本上就可以做渲染渲做渲染了
那这里面的话呢
我还跟同学们讲一个另外一个很关键的概念
就是纹理压缩
大家会觉得很奇怪了
哎今天我们不是讲渲染算法吗
为什么你老师围着数据跟我讲的
现在我讲的就是渲染的一切的基础叫RENDERABLE
那RENDERABLE里面呢就是可被绘制的东西呢
其中有很重要的component叫做纹理
那纹理是不是可以像我们在电脑上
比如说打开一个图像
打开一个照片对吧
你可以发现照片会存成什么格式呢
比如说JPG格式啊
这个就是这个这个这个这个PNG格式啊
或者什么很多很分散的格式
但是呢我想让同学们建立一个概念
就是说在游戏引擎里面
纹理不是像我们想的图片文件那样去存在
比如说像BP基本上没有人会用的
我们一般会把纹理进行压缩
那有其实大家知道
就是说在计算机的那个照片的话是会被压缩的
大家如果比较一下
没有压缩的b mp格式和压缩过的街拍格式
是不是差别特别大对吧
有的时候能差到十倍以上
但是在游戏引擎里面绘制系统里面
我们的图片压缩不能够用那些非常好的算法
为什么呢
因为这些压缩算法它不能够随机访问
就是说比如说我给你一个JPG文件
我突然要看坐标7567832的这个点的话
他很难快速的去拿到
而且呢它的这个计算的复杂度非常的高
而在计算机的这个图
图片那个texture压缩的时候呢
我们一般采取的思想
就是那个绘制里面一般采取的思想是什么呢
叫block based
就是说我们把图片切成一个个小块
最经典的就是一个4×4的小块
然后呢我们去压缩它
这里我给大家介绍一个非常经典的一个
一个算法
就是那个就是在DXD这种文件里面
它很简单
比如说我有一个4×4的这样的
一个小的色块
我去找它最亮的就是颜色最鲜艳的那个点
和颜色最暗的那个点
那我们就认为这里面其他所有的点
就是这两个点之间的差值
因为呢在很多图片啊
它相邻的像素之间其实都有一定的
我们叫做coherence
就是关联度
所以呢你就可以把它的最大值
最小值以及每个像素存一个诶
我是离你最大值近
还是离最小值近的一个比例关系
其实我就可以近似的去表达
我这个像素的这个这个这个小色块的颜色
其实整个在计算机图形学里面的
texture compression都是基于这个思想
我们叫做block compression思想
那么在这个就是DX里面的话呢
最经典的就是我们叫DXT系列的这个压缩算法
全家桶对吧
一整套
那现在呢研发了像BC系列
最新的应该已经到了b c seven了
就BC7了
那么但是呢
其实在这个这个算法其实有非常大的好处啊
它好在什么地方
举个例子啊
你你生成了一个纹理
它可以在CPU上实时的把你压缩好
因为它这个算法无论是压缩还是解压缩
效率都非常的高
那么另外一派呢
就是我们现在在手机上用的比较多的
就是STC这个算法呢我也不是特别熟
因为我一直在做这个PC和主机的游戏
但是呢它的它的分块就不再是严格的
就是4×4了
它可以任意的形状
而且呢据说是HTC的压缩的这个效果是最好的
解压缩的效率也不低
但是呢就是说它的压缩的预算稍微有点费
就不能够我们叫做on the flight
就是在运行中进行压缩
但是呢它整个计算机的这个
就是这个渲染系统的话
我们的纹理压缩的基本逻辑
是按这个思想来进行压缩的
所以这件事情为什么大家要知道呢
因为当你去构建游戏引擎的时候
其实你对texture的压缩和管理
是一个非常重要的一个模块
而且你下载到你的先看里面的话呢
你肯定是基本上应该是个压缩过的
这个数据格式好
所以有了这样的一些东西的话呢
我们今天的一个最基础的绘制
基础的东西基本上是讲明白了对吧
那这里面的话呢
我们就讲这个rainbow到底是怎么来的呢
我们一般会讲说这个东西
我们要放到工具里面去讲
是你要用大量的工具去构建
那样的小屏模型
但是呢我觉得作为引擎开发
特别是做这个到图形这一趴的时候
其实你需要对工具有所了解
那我们去构建一个物体的话呢
最经典的是什么
3D max玛雅对吧
包括现在越来越流行的blender
我我其实非常看好blender
就是说因为它是越来越强大了
那大家在这里面就是点线面
我去构建我要的各种各样酷炫的模型对吧
比如说我们经常最著名的是做一个枪
我要卡线
卡住那一个个关键的点
由粗到细的构建这个模型
但这个呢实际上在十几年前是非常的火了
但是呢现在受到了巨大的冲击
但是就是我们的ZBRUSH就是雕刻性的工具
就是大家知道我们在真实的世界
塑造一个形体的时候
就是sculpture嘛
就雕刻家对吧
我就可以不断的把这个
就是把这些材料给它切削掉
然后形成我的形状
但实际上的话
这种雕刻行为在计算机里面可以更自由
我不对
不仅可以切削掉哇
可以把它往上拎出来
那这样的话艺术家可以构建一些更加自由的
这些形体
那这个呢zbrush base的这样的一种
就是说sculpture的这种啊素材生成工具的话呢
现在其实也是越来越火
那么另外一个第3part呢
就是这个大家知道了
最著名的这个扫描
我不知道同学们有没有见过
就是哎手机上有些app
你绕着一个物体拍几张照片
他就能把3D的东西给你建起来
对不对
你们觉得很酷
这个呢也是得益于我们现在的人
这个深度学习啊
包括这些这个registration这些算法的提升
所以其实在我们的3A的游戏行业里面
就是基于实体扫描的这种模型也越来越多
比如像这里面这样的一个非常复杂的
古代的武士的盔甲
那我们通过一圈扫描的话
能形成非常高精度的
达到十几个亿面级别的
这样的一个这个非常的这个细腻的
这样的一个网格
这个精度也是远远超过人手工构建的
那么最后一个呢也是现在发展非常非常快的
就是说诶我们能通过一些算法
通过一些规则自动的生成这样的一个网格
这里面我们讲的是个胡迪尼这样的
一个很强大的工具
它能生成漂亮的这个地形的网格
对不对
但实际上的话呢
现在有些前沿的人工智能的这个研发的话
它可以生成一个啊很多
在Mac上我们要的这些细节
我个人认为的话呢
这也是这个游戏引擎工业的话
未来一个很重要的一个发展方向
因为我相信就是他能把我们的艺术家
从越来越繁琐的这种细节的
这种工作中解放出来
能够真正专注在创意上面
就不用再花那么多时间做细节了
我用人工智能把你自动给补上
那其实这四种方法呢各有利弊对吧
那其实呢有的更flexible一点
有的呢可能更这个难以调整一点
比如说scan
大家会觉得诶是不是特别方便
我把一个东西放在这一扫描一下就得到了
对不对
但是它有个很大的难题是什么
你首先得有这个东西对吧
所以说我们以前有个很著名的故事
就是某个大型大厂
他们为了做一个游戏
先去逛淘宝
买到这些东西
扫描过来
我们就可以进入到我们的游戏了
所以呢其实不同的工艺制作方法
它会产生不一样的数据
而这些数据的话呢就是我们计算机绘制的粮食
就是我们的口粮
对不对
那为什么我会在这一趴里面跟同学们讲
这些资产怎么去构造呢
这就想引出我今天的最后一趴了
就是讲渲染的
今天讲渲染的最后一趴
就是现代的游戏引擎的pipeline
在往哪个方向去发展
因为刚才我给大家介绍了
比如说像这个mesh啊
some mesh啊
纹理啊
Shader
大家听上去是不是虽然说有点难啊
如果没有基础会有点难
但是实际上还是可以理解的不行
看两遍应该也能理解
但是呢其实现在游戏
它的发展的工艺变化非常大
也就是说比如说现在现在大家玩的游戏
你们有没有发现就是细节越来越多对吧
而且呢地图越来越大
我们叫做开放世界
那么我一个同样一个射击游戏
同样的精度
如果是传统的射击游戏和开放世界的设计游戏
它的在每一帧里面
你看到的这个这个数据量可以大十倍以上
一个数量级
同样就是随着我们刚才讲的那种sculpting
就是ZBRUSH这样的工具的普及
包括3D扫描的普及
其实我们得到的这个模型的数据量是越来越大
这里面举个例子
一个很简单的一个小雕像
你推进之后
你发现他有无数的细节对吧
我相信我们的小伙伴们
就是现在如果你喜欢玩那个3A游戏的话
你很在意就是说这个场景的精度够不够
这个东西当然是非常非常的重要
但是呢这恰恰又是对现代引擎的基础架构
产生了巨大巨大的冲击
所以我特别想让同学们建立一个概念
就是说这个游戏引擎的绘制系统
它不是一个静态的
它的技术一直在往前去进步
那其实这里面的话呢有一个很重要的发展方向
我们叫做就class base的这个mesh pipeline
这是一条新的
这个就是我们的这个这个模型表达的一个管线
它的基本思想呢其实在很早就有了
大概2015年吧
最著名的那个就是啊
育碧他们在做那个就是刺客信条大革命
那一作的时候大家回想一下那个游戏长什么样
是不是有很多非常华丽的这种建筑
对不对
很多很多的细节
其实他那个时候就提出了这样的一个
基于class pine
那么经过56年的发展
同时硬件呢也越来越成熟了
实际上有越来越多的引擎
再往这一条新的拍拉机转去去去去转移
那这个这个pipeline它的核心思想是什么呢
在这节课上我没有办法详详细的展开啊
我只跟大家讲一些最基础的概念
就是说当我面对一个非常精细的模型的时候
我把它分成一个一个的小的
我们叫做max也好
我们叫做一个啊
小的这个这个这个小cluster也好
whatever对吧
那么他每一个小MESLIDE呢就是固定的
比如说32个三角形或者64个三角形
当我看到这条龙
这条龙大概是几10万的面片
我把它分成了很多很多小的
64个面片的mes
那为什么要这么去做呢
因为是这样的
就是现代计算机啊
我们的显卡已经能够非常高效的
就是说创建很多很多的几何细节
基于数据
而并不需要像传统的我们的管线说
你要预先把vertex buffer
index buffer构建好
就是把那个卖时间传进去
它的很多的几何是可以凭空算出来的
而且你给他一个三角形
它可以给你生成无数个三角形
所以呢当你把每一个MASA的大小固定住之后
它的计算其实都是高效的一致的
大家想象一下刚才我讲的那个GPU的架构
它是不是有很多很多小盒
所以你看到这条龙虽然很复杂
但是呢他很多的计算是不是都是完全一致的
所以说class base mesh pine a核心就是用这个思想
这个讲起来就比较复杂了
这里面的话呢我们就讲硬件的升级了
就是最早的那个大家想到了学统计学的时候
你们学到的是什么
就是哎就是我们的构建好这个模型
构建好材质
然后呢有一个叫vs
就是那个每个顶点的着色器
还有个PS
每个像素的主色系
对不对
这是个经典的一个pipeline
其实最经典的连vs p s都没有了
那从这个十几年前我们发现诶
我们可以在显卡里创建很多很精细的集合
我们加入了这个就是比如像whole shader对吧
这个这个DOMINSHADER
还有这个geometry shader
它的核心目的是什么呢
就是你可以把你放进来的三角形
进行无限的细化
生成我们想要的细节
但是的话呢其实随着最新的这些硬件的发展
我们干脆就提供了一个mesh shader
或者叫amplification shader
这两个两个不同的SHADER
不他的名字在open jia
VULKAN和direct里面都不太一样
但是它的核心想法就是你可以用一个算法
基于数据凭空生成很多的集合
而且你可以根据它离你相机的远近
选择它的精度
那这样的话我们机CPU就是我们的显卡
处理起来最高效的
是不是都是大小一致的一个个小块呢
大家想象一下这个是不是更快
这个是有点抽象
大家去想象一下
其实这个就是基于这个cluster base的
这个mesh pipeline呢
他对程序员的要求是比以前高很多了
那么我们要做大量的处理和运算
而且这个代码写起来已经不太好去理解
但是呢它的好处是什么
它可以产生无数的细节
而且呢就是我们的艺术家可以自由的去发挥
而且我个人认为呢
这是一个非常值得大家关注的一个前沿的引擎
的一个发展方向
那这里面给大家举个例子
比如说如果我们把这个这个这个这个
这个这个怪物叫阿玛提诺
我们如果学过通讯学的同学
都知道这个怪物的名字
那么它有很多很多的面片
对不对
我把它分成了mesh的话
你会发现当你的相机在移动的时候
这个怪物就是他会会被裁剪掉
就以前我们的裁剪只能按照物体去裁剪
但是你会发现
现在这个时候
我可以把他手的一部分就裁剪来了
因为每一个method他有他自己的绑定
我们在我们的GPU上可以实时的算出来
说在目前的这个相机的情况下
你这个东西不需要去绘制了
所以它的效率是非常非常高的
那这里面的话呢就不得不提一下
我们大名鼎鼎的那个虚幻引擎的NT对吧
大家都知道虚幻引擎
那个叫这个像素级的网格密度
其实now night呢
你可以认为是这个思想又往前走了一步了
就做得更加的工业化
更加的成熟
但是呢这也是我们认为就是现代引擎啊
它的拍发展的一个重要的方向
所以这节课呢我们给大家教育了
教教给大家了最基础的游戏引擎架构的思想
包括让大家去理解什么是显卡
但是当同学们真的到这个行业里面的话呢
我们是非常希望同学们能够关注一些最前沿的
这些技术发展的趋势
其实呢渲染这个系统你怎么去理解它
我们这节课呢也就是就第一节课
我想给同学们建立这样几个基础的概念
第一个的话呢就是说嗯游戏引擎的绘制系统
它是一个工程科学
它是深度依赖于你对硬件的现代图形
硬件的理解
所以说如果你想成为一个graphics engineer
你必须要花时间去理解显卡的架构是怎么回事
知道它的性能卡点在哪里对吧
就是各种棒的这个水口就飞出来就可以了
那么第二个的话呢就是说其实在游戏里面
我们核心要解决的就是mesh模型
材质这些数据之间的关系
那么最经典的mesh和smash
就是一个非常好的学习方法
但是呢在最前沿的话
我们有些变化
第三个呢
我希望同学们建立了一个一个概念的话
就是说我们在这个绘制的时候
尽可能的通过一些运算
把绘制的东西减到越少越好
这样的话能够把性能变到最大
所以visibility非常的重要
那这里面跟大家分享一个大神的一句话
我忘了这个大神是谁了
他曾经以前有人问他说
哎
大神这个你认为优化的最和高的境界是什么呢
那个大神说了一句叫do nothing
然后很多人就懵了
说DNI是不是我什么都不要做了
其实大神的意思是什么
就是你要通过你的算法
让计算机尽可能少的做事情
那你的效率一定是最高的
所以叫do nothing
所以呢当我们去做这个优化的时候
我们尽可能让我们的计算机读nothing
那么最后一点呢
也是我认为是非常重要的一个趋势
就是说越来越多的绘制运算
包括一些复杂的处理
我们都从CPU上移到了GPU
利用现在GPU10倍以上的高速的处理性能
包括这个里面呢有一个大词啊
我们叫做GPU driven对吧
这个词的意思是什么呢
就是说把很多需要在CP上做的一些复杂运算
比如说我们后面可以讲的像动画系统对吧
我们教给大家的是最经典的动画系统架构
但是呢其实现在很多动画系统
全部都移到显卡上来做了
这也是那个就GPU来帮CPU分担负担
的一个重要的发展方式
所以呢当大家去理解我们的绘制系统的话
把这四点记牢在脑子里面
基本上你就知道这个绘制技术发展的这个大的
这个方向
基本上我们今天这节课的内容
已经讲的差不多了
那个不好意思
时间有点长
确实没有办法
以为我已经是这个就是怎么说呢
千挑万选
把很多的能够跳到的东西都跳掉了
但是还是要塞这么多
那么那剩下的时间呢我想给同学们讲一下
就是这个我们期待已久的
也是我们欠大家的
就是我们小引擎的项目
实际上上次小引擎的话呢
这里面我是特别要感谢一下我们的这个课程组
同学嘛
因为上周我们为什么小引擎被delay呢
就是因为我们发现就是那个引擎写的太抽象
太复杂
而且的话呢就是那个代码写的也不够好
还有不方便同学们阅读
所以其实在过去的这个
差不多有两周时间不到吧
整个团队几乎每天晚上都通宵
就是再去写
我们其实一开始第一版的小引擎
大概是1万多行代码
这次整改完的话
小引擎代码大概是2万多行
2万多行
大部分基本上都是重写的
然后呢
我们希望能够给大家一个相对完整的框架
那么所以呢昨天夜里面吧
我们拿到小引擎的最新版本了
然后呢
我本来想
今天我想怎么去跟大家讲一下小引擎怎么用
因为我觉得把这些代码扔给大家
同学们也不知道怎么去看
怎么从哪儿下手
所以呢我现在有没有办法在现场给大家去演示
小米怎么怎么去看
所以呢
我就昨天晚上在家里面录制了两个视频给大家
因为我们家里条件有限啊
所以这个视频上面声音有很多的噪音
大家先听一听
首先的话呢大家去看一下小引擎
如果跑起来
它的编辑器和它的引擎应该是什么样子的啊
大家好
这是我们的小引擎
然后呢中间这个窗口就是我们的编辑界面
大家在用这个界面的时候
注意一定要把中文输入法关掉
然后呢首先是按住鼠标右键
这样你就可以就是上下左右的调整你的相机
然后呢ASDW就像一个FPS游戏一样
你就可以去这样飞来飞去
看到这里面的东西
然后呢这是中间最重要的一个就是编辑窗口
然后你的鼠标左键点住每一个物体
它就会呢有一个坐标轴显示
就表明这个物体你选中了
然后呢每个物体选中的时候呢
它就会出现很多的component
比如说在这边的panel
就是各个component的这里面
可以看到它很多的那个属性
这些属性呢都是用反射的方法自动生成的
这个编辑UI
但是同学们如果不明白
没关系
先假设就是东西自动给你生成好了
然后呢在这边的话呢
就是当你去动它任何一个数值的时候
这边你可以看到它的数据的变化
比如像这个那个墙
它实际上是有碰撞体的
那这里面的话呢我们可以看到有些物体
比如说看一下一个小小的
比如说这个你看到没有
它其实只有那个位移和mesh
所以呢这个它就没有碰撞
就是我们为了给大家展示清楚
然后呢比较复杂的是我们的主角
然后呢主角你去选中它
你可以发现它不仅有位移
还有他的动画
我们做了一个非常简单的动画component的
它你会下载资源
同学们可以打开自己研究
然后呢它还有就是MOTO就控制它的移动
我们是设置了一个就是移动速度
还有呢就是它的那个相机
因为一旦进入游戏模式的时候
相机就起作用了
所以这个虽然很小
但是它其实是一个完整的一个游戏引擎架构
然后呢它的整个引擎呢就是作为核心
然后外面加了一层编辑器
那怎么样去切换呢
上面有个小小的按钮
你点它
你看它这边有editor mode嘛
就告诉你现在我在编辑模式
但是呢如果你点它一下诶
我们就进入了游戏模式
这样这个小人物就开始进入游戏的T
可以叫动词了
当然现在的动画模型做的模式做的非常的简单
所以他就在循环播放一个动画
也不会停下来
因为后面真正的所以这速度和位移的话
去调整动画
包括在比如说站在那idol和漫步
和这个基本的动画之间切换的话呢
实际上是要有动画不烂的一些基础的
我们在这么短的时间里面
暂时先不开放这些东西
然后呢刚才讲的像这些东西
它有碰撞
所以它要拦住
有个简单的物理的阻挡
那么像这个呢就是没有做碰撞
你可以穿过去
这也让同学们知道就是不同的component
怎么在一起作用
那么这个时候如果你觉得游戏的这个模型
我已经看清楚了
我我在哦整个这个引擎的话呢
现在我们实现了一个简单的PV2的材质
所以大家可以看到这个光照
基本上也能看到一些很多的细节
然后呢但是我们现在为了简单
就是先使用了那个forward的那个CD啊
这个时候同学们如果想进入到编辑模式的话呢
可以按一个out
然后呢鼠标又出来了
然后切换到游戏模型模式啊
editor模式在这里面的话呢
大家可以看到就是说哎这些角色就会停在这
这个小橘子还蛮可爱的
上面还有一个小小的我们的引擎的logo在上面
对吧
piano的引擎
然后呢这个编辑器里面呢还有很多细节
比如说这边是场景中所有的物体的列表
就是这是一个标准的一个游戏
编辑器的一个架构
就是object list
就是所有的对象类的
包括这个角色自己呀
这是角色自己
还有哥哥的墙体物体
然后呢还我们还做了一个content browser
就是说你所有的资产在这边你都能看见
比如说我们一定要好的各种物体
各种东西
同学们在这边的话呢
如果点击的话
其实他可以再加载进去的
所以说这个小小的编辑器啊
麻雀虽小
五脏俱全
所以整个小引擎团队还是蛮辛苦的
他们这一个多星期疯狂的加班
然后基本上我们想给大家一个完整的现代
游戏引擎以及编辑器的一个架构
好的这个说实话我昨天看到了还是蛮感动的
就是同学们是这样的
就是说虽然这个是一个公益课嘛
但是大家一旦做进去了之后就忍不住了
就说我们想再做的再好一点
然后呢尽可能给大家一些我们理解的引擎的
最规规范的一些架构的一些知识
所以做了很多很多的小细节
那么接下来呢我还录了另外一个视频
就是说啊真的想钻进去写自己引擎的同学对吧
我们这个课程
很多同学是要立志要做自己的作业引擎的
我们的口号叫课程结束
人均一个字眼引擎
那我们就要把给大家看代码
所以呢我这个也没有办法在现场打call vc
所以昨天夜里在家里面又录了另外一个视频
就是带大家简单的go through一下
我们的源代码是怎么架的
好的
我现在跟同学们简单的讲一下
我们的引擎源码结构
那你其实拿到我们的引擎之后呢
无论你是从GITHUB还是我们的安装包
你首先可以看到这样的一个解码出来
这样一个结构
当然这个build这个目录需要你自己构建的
然后呢这里面的话有个read me
如果大家打开的话
你可以看到就是说对于不同的平台的话呢
它会有不同的这个SIMC指令
大家正确的run
比如说windows run cmc指令之后呢
你就可以生成啊
你想要的这个工程文件
一般我们会放到这个build目录下
大家注意这个build目录要自己创建的
你会得到这样的一个solution文件
那么好
那这个时候呢
我们拿到了我们的整个这个源码嘛
那这个源码的话
大家如果看的话
在这边其实它的结构呢
引擎最核心的叫pilot one time
就是这个结构
如果大家点开呢
你会发现它是严格的
按照我们的引擎的框架
就是从平台层
核心层
资源层
功能层
然后一层层垒起来
那么编辑器呢我们把它单独做成一个工程了
那这样也是以适合引擎的核心做出区别
那么然后在这里面的话呢
大家可以看到
就是说我们的SHADER是单独放在一个工程里面
因为SHADER比较特殊
它虽然也是源码
我们选的选的是这个GLSL
但是的话呢它编译出的binary的话呢
需要单独的去管理
那这里面比较复杂呢
是有一个就是PRECOMPOLE这个这个文件夹
这个这个工程
这个工程是什么呢
就是说我们在这里面的话呢
用了类似于虚幻的这种反射机制
就是说我们在C语言里面
定义了各种的数据类型
然后呢我们做了一个decoration
它就自动的反射出了
你在这个资资产资源里面
应该用什么方式去读取
这个的话呢
实际上是游戏引擎非常重要的一个东西
那么就是说简单来讲的话呢
在这个引擎里面的话呢
就这段这里面生成的代码全是全自动生成的
以后我们再讲到资源系统的时候
会跟同学们详细的去讲
那在功能层里面呢
大家可以看到就是标准的像动画呀
component control啊
input怎么一层层怎么去管理
那么这里面简单跟大家讲一下
你在哪去找到我们游戏的资产
在目录下呢
你可以看到有就是有一个字目录叫做啊
就比如在那个根这个根目录下
你可以看到有个目录叫做
engine里面有一个目录叫做asset
那这个asset里面的话呢就放了我们所有的资产
那你们举个例子
比如说我们有个叫level
大家可以发现我们是用JASON去存我们的数据
那我们点开一个关卡
你发现这个数据
那引擎是怎么读这个数据呢
其实大家可以发现
就是在我们的资源层里面
有一个叫resource type的这个文件夹
这里面其实我们在C语言中
定义了每一种资源的描述
比如说你看到一个宏叫做decoction type
它就说明这是一种我们可以反射的
就是可以读进来了资源类型
然后呢这里面的每一个结构它是一层能签到
比如这里面我们会定义每一个物体的instance
它应该怎么样
如果大家去看一下它的定义的话
你发现它也是一层就是带反射的这个类型
那这里面的话每一个变量名
实际上到最后就会变成JSON里面的一个描述文件
你看到没有
这里面有name啊
每个物体有name
然后呢每个物体有它的这个啊transform位移
位移里面也包括position
rotation和那个就是他的那个啊skill
实际上的话呢和这里面的是一一对应的
但这个技术点相对来讲比较复杂
我们今天不展开
但是呢同学们按照这个思路可以逐步的理解
整个就是polo的引擎架构
那我们为什么去这样去做呢
实际上我们是希望给同学们建立一个
相对规范的现代引擎的体系结构
也是我们尽我们所能吧
就是说尽可能把一些经典的这个
商业引擎的建结构教给大家
这个就是说其实这里面的话呢
小引擎虽然很小啊
2万多行
但是呢它里面还是有一些就是有意思的
一些结构和和那个架构
比如像反射对吧
这个其实跟虚幻引擎的基础结构是很像很像的
但这个东西的话呢
可能要到后面的课程同学们才能理解
所以他拿了小引擎之后呢
别慌
就是那个我们的第一个我我我先不剧透吧
我们的第一个作业
大家先呢把它编译过去就可以了
那在这个小引擎呢
这版那个发布的时候
我们会把基本的编辑器啊
基本的这些物体啊
这些对象的东西全部都有
它其实是一个小小的游戏的框架了
刚才我看到很多同学说我的毕设就已经有了
确实是你拿这个小引擎改吧
改吧的话
我就做个毕设应该还是蛮酷的
然后呢
我们在后面的话呢会把一些呃更好的graphic
因为我们这次时间仓促啊
我们把那个我们还是用OBJ这个模式
我们后面可能会切到那个FBX
因为方便同学们构建自己想要的
各种各样的模型
包括我们会把这个mesh sumesh的整个结构
给大家搭起来
包括我们会就是可以跟同学们作业
或者是我们自己做
就跟那同学做一些简单的animation blending系统
这样你可以看起来像个真的游戏一样的
这个人跑起来跳起来都会不太一样对吧
那那么的话呢就是说包括呃我们这次呢
那个其实课程组还是挺努力的
我们支持了这个windows Mac啊
还有那个LINUX
但是max的m one的话
好像现在还不支持后面的呢
我们还要再优化一下
那么因为我上节课也讲了
就是说我们看了一下ECS的代码
实在是太抽象了
而且本身的话扩展性也不是特别好
所以呢我们把ECS这一趴先撸掉
就以后再说
包括在这个架构中呢
我们就没有把这个多线程的架构放出来
因为那个会极大的降低整个代码的可读性
和可可观的
因为我觉得同学们一开始的话呢
还是要经常加断点
去看这个功能到底是怎么跟进去了
这个主要是以学习为目的的
这个就是说这个引擎架构
所以我们是希望就是先把最基础的东西
通过代码
就是就是我们经常有个说法
叫做你代码写的好的
不用写注释
大家就能感觉得到
那这里面的话呢
就是我们同学们剧透一下我们的作业吧
就是首先的话呢你得把小引擎下载来了对吧
那有两个两个下载渠道
就第一你可以从我们的官网上
有一个有一个下载好的包
你也可以访问我们的GITHUB
在上面去去下载引擎
这样的话我们后面根据同学们的反馈啊
包括同学们如果写的一些非常优秀的代码
我们也可以考虑mg进去
这样同学们可以一直看到他的更新
这个呢我们也是第一次这样去做
所以啊可能会有些地方一开始会遇到一些问题
希望同学们给我们多多的这个反馈
告诉我们该怎么去优化对吧
然后呢
希望这个小小的三角形
能带着我们真的进入到游戏引擎的这个世界
那我们的第一次作业是什么
其实非常的简单
就同学们把我们的小引擎下载下来
然后呢你能编译出来
然后呢你跑起来截一张图
然后呢提交就可以了
因为这事虽然说你不用写一行代码
但是你真的把整个这个工程搭起来
就像刚才我的视频中那样
看看每个资产是怎么放放的
每个资产是怎么定义的
那个数据和类
每个数据源代码是怎么放的
实际上的话会帮助你建立一个
最基础的游戏工程的这样的一个意识
这个东西的话呢
我认为作为游戏引擎真的动手的第一节课
我认为非常重要
就像当年我去学游戏引擎的时候
我并不是一上来就去写什么东西的对吧
虽然我们知道
我那时候已经学了很多图形学的算法
但是我大量的时间在干嘛呢
是我先去静静地去读别人的代码
跑别人的引擎跑了跑
然后加很多断点去看到每一步发生了什么事情
这样我其实心中就有感觉了
我知道这个东西是怎么做的
所以呢我们做了一个这样的一个一个
就是同学们可以到我们的课程官网
然后呢有一个作业提交系统
这个是我们可以games一起做的
同学们你们做完了的这个这个这个作业
就是那张截图的话
同学们写上自己的名字
按照我们的规范就提交到我们的官网上
我们每一次作业的话呢
在我们官网上都有非常非常详细的说明
那么如果大家觉得不清楚的话
一定要告诉我们
因为我们有很多的共创观
我们还有很多的微信群
所以同学们可以在群里面
把我们做的不周到的地方反馈给我们
包括其实像上一次我们的课件中
有一张虚幻的图讲错了
那个后来有个同学告诉我们
我们还当时觉得哇这个幸好他告诉我们
我们现在正在想办法更新我们的视频
去解决这个问题
因为这一次呢是我们第一次去筹备这个课
其实过去的差不多四五天了吧
我们的团队十几个人基本上都没怎么睡觉
就是每天都搞到四五点钟
有些同学到昨天到现在还在通宵
就是我们是非常非常希望能给大家准备一个
尽可能好的课
我们希望我们讲的每个东西
都是尽可能是正确的
但是真的很多错误在所难免
也希望同学们给我们多多指正
好的
这就是我今天课程的全部的内容
那同学们有什么问题吗
呃其实GO就是一个非常典型的
就有同学问我说引擎中还有其他因素的案例吗
其实JO就是game option
就是个很典型的因素案例
比如说刚才你在资产里面打开的
每一个GO的定义的话
就是每一个比如说角色啊强啊
那个地面上的方块
它在数据中就是一个定义
比如说一个方块它放在哪啊
它是长多大
什么样子对吧
但是呢我在这个关卡里面
我那个方块可以放十个
放100个
我那个墙可以放很多个
对不对
可以横着放
竖着放
那每一个墙它其实就是一个instance
所以instance的话呢在游戏中的案例特别的多
再举个例子
比如说音乐或者音效
那么我的一声音效
比如说呃子弹打中墙的声音
大家想想这是不是它的定义
对不对
但是的话当我在一个游戏中的话
你拿着加特林对着墙一扫
是不是一瞬间可以听到十几个子弹
黑的黑得到墙的声音
那每个内每个声音呢就叫instance
所以包括像粒子系统啊
像地表上的这种草啊
植被啊
全是用伊森的概念去做的
啊这个同学问的就比较专业的
他就问我说mesh shader和class based match
未来会怎么发展
那我个人呢
这这这纯纯属是一家之言啊
就是因为我们也是在行业的前端
去看这些行业的发展
我个人认为这是未来的发展的方向
为什么呢
因为硬件不可能会越来越简单对吧
他一定会越来越复杂
而且功能会越来越强大
所以的话呢其实mesh shader它它的核心计算理念
就是把所有的因素啊全部并行化掉之后的话
包括每一个单元只处理简单的运算
这个思想实际上我认为是正确的
至少在未来10年一定是这个方向去发展
所以呢我们把一个复杂的游戏世界
拆解成一个一个个固定小的单元
然后用这些B进化的计算迅速的完成的话
我个人认为是未来的发展的方向
所以的话那个就是说我认为这个pipeline的话
未来可能会取代掉
今天我在课程中讲的那个最经典的pipeline
但是呢我觉得你要去理解那个pipeline的话呢
经典pipeline还是要学
因为你要去理解
因为即使切到那个pipeline的话
材质网格index
包括根据材质进行世界的破分
这个基础逻辑还是需要在的
啊有个同学问我一个很扎心的问题
就是引擎有必要自写这个渲染管线吗
呃其实呢就是很多的引擎都会去写
自己的渲染管线
但是我个人认为其实渲染这个问题
就像我一上来就讲的就是游戏game engine的渲染
它是个工业化的问题
其实只要是工业化的问题呢
你会发现随着时间的积累
在同样的这个技术水平下
大家最后的解决方案是大同小异的
所以呢我会认为就是渲染管线的话呢
尽可能的去多学习
多去向别人请教
关注行业最前沿的发展方向
然后呢选择最主流的方案去构建你的管线
就是特别特别特别的不一样的关系
我个人认为的话呢
就是它维护和发展起来挑战还是非常大的
这是也不是我们特别推荐的一种方法
所以我会建议就是说你自己写是可以的
没有问题
但是你的架构
尽可能要符合整个行业和工业的标准
哇这个这个问题有个同学问我的问题
这个就太难了
叫图形代码有没有更好的第八个方法
呃
实话实说
这个问题非常的难
因为如果大家真的做了这个图形程序员的话
我自己就是图形程序员出身嘛
那我们的debug
应该是仅次于服务器端的那个难度吧
因为你的很多计算全是在GPU中
然后GPU你就像那个你的子弹打出去了
你根本不知道在里面发生了什么
然后最后一个结果给你出来了
那实际上的话呢就现在的这个就是显卡driver
包括各家厂商提供了很多的第八个工具
比如说每个像素的
每一到周末可以看到它的数值的变化
包括SHADER可以PERCEPT去debug
但是呢这些都比当年要好很多了
但我个人认为的话
就当你去写图形程序的时候呢
一定要非常的谨慎
而且我会我一般建议的方法是
不要一次性把所有的代码全写完
最好把你的算法拆成很多小布
然后呢每一个小步实现验证
反复验证
证明没有问题了
再往上再加一步
这样的话你出了问题之后
你可以至少退回去
然后再看哪一步错了
千万不要看到一个算法特别牛逼
哐哐就把它全写了
那到时候你死了都不知道死在哪里
所以说图形引擎的debug呢
实际上啊难度是蛮大的
而且特别需要这个程序员的经验
就是他要经验非常的成熟
好的
因为今天的时间比较长了
我看了一下
我们讲了将近100分钟了
所以要不我们今天的课程先这样
再次谢谢同学们
就是那个这么好学
在这个假期里面
还是一起来进入到游戏引擎的知识世界
那我们期待呢
在下一周我们继续深入的讲那个图形渲染对吧
这也是游戏引擎中最sexy的一个部分
大家能看到好的
那今天我们先到这里
谢谢大家